did chrissy look familiar before she was
crumpled up does a cleaned up vechna
seem like someone you've seen before
from twilight to game of thrones to
nightmare on elm street here's where
you've seen the new stranger things cast
before
arguably the most meaningful addition to
the stranger things roster of characters
in season 4 is eddie munson the
denim-wearing hard-rocking king of
hawkins high school's hellfire club due
to a series of unfortunate circumstances
eddie ends up blamed for the murder of
chrissy cunningham forcing him to run
for his life his predilections for heavy
metal and dungeons and dragons make him
an easy scapegoat for the town's anxiety
a scenario not unheard of in reality's
version of the satanic panic that
occurred in the 80s and 90s
making matters worse for eddie he soon
finds himself thrown into a world of
danger demons and alternate dimensions
joseph quinn brings eddie munson to life
in stranger things swore and does a
fantastic job in the role channeling a
mania that brings a distinctly new kind
of energy to the hawkins gang a british
actor quinn has played major roles in
the bbc series dickensian and les
miserables as well as howard's end on
stars he's also appeared in hbo's
catherine the great and played a minor
role in a season seven episode of game
of thrones
it's very metal he did that's all i'm
saying
the yin to eddie munson's yang jason
carver is the golden boy of hawkins
indiana the captain of the basketball
team and an orator of many lightly
biblical speeches jason's life takes a
dark turn when his longtime girlfriend
chrissy cunningham is brutally murdered
believing eddie to be the perpetrator
jason and his crew of teenage athletes
begin investigating and deploying their
own disturbing brand of vigilante
justice jason's heart might start off in
the right place but he gets sucked into
a dangerous breed of fear-mongering
actor mason dye already had an
impressive resume of tv roles before
landing the part of jason in stranger
things you may know him as tom galligan
in bosch damon from finding carter or
garrett from season 4 of the 2011 teen
wolf reboot dye has also been featured
prominently in a couple of web series
such as secret diary of an american
cheerleader and roommates
what's jonathan byers to do after moving
far away from his childhood home and
girlfriend to finish up high school in
sunny california make a new stoner
friend and start getting high of course
jonathan's new predilection for cannabis
is the source of some great comedic
moments in stranger things four as is
his new best friend argyle from his
extra-long hair and his love of
recreational drugs to his job as a pizza
delivery driver argyle is the complete
california stereotype hand rolled into
one chilled out package
why do you just go to the van
and do your thing
huh purple laundry delay if you've seen
2019's book smart then you're already
familiar with eduardo franco's unique
brand of comedy in the olivia wilde
directed teen comedy franco plays theo a
character who bears a striking
similarity to argyle franco is also
featured in movies like the binge and
super intelligence from 2020 as well as
2021's we broke up franco previously got
major screen time on netflix as spencer
diaz in american vandal in addition to
other tv appearances on adam ruins
everything gamer's guide to pretty much
everything and gabby's dollhouse among
others
after entering the secret site of the
nina project eleven takes a journey into
her memories specifically some of her
most traumatic days as a test subject of
dr martin brenner within those memories
she re-encounters peter an assistant to
the good doctor who seems at first to
have her best interests and heart but
peter contains multitudes imdb describes
him as friendly orderly and peter even
though that isn't his original name it
isn't long before his involvement in the
greater story of the show comes rolling
out in a series of wild twists and turns
jamie campbell bauer does a phenomenal
job blending the creepy and the calm in
his performance as peter aka one aka
henry krill and aka vekna bauer is
perhaps best known for his career on the
big screen which includes the role of
caius in the twilight films and the role
of anthony in tim burton's 2007
adaptation of sweeney todd he's also
appeared in films like rock and roll
london boulevard and fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald in which he
played a young version of the title
villain on tv bauer has appeared in
shows like camelot will and 2009's the
prisoner
the protagonists of stranger things face
many different enemies in season 4 from
the supernatural to the mundane one of
the bigger foes of the season is
lieutenant colonel sullivan a military
man who believes that eleven is a threat
to us national security and therefore
must be apprehended and possibly killed
sullivan deploys some pretty
reprehensible tactics to accomplish his
mission proving himself to be more than
capable as one of the show's main bad
guys it's possible that you'd recognize
actor sherman augustus from his brief
career in the nfl but it's more likely
that you know him from one of his many
many film and tv roles a second degree
black belt in taekwondo augustus starred
in some major on-screen fights as
nathaniel moon in amc's into the
badlands his other projects include
what's love got to do with it
rumplestiltskin the mexican and zigzag
in addition to stranger things and into
the badlands augustus's tv resume
includes similar roles like marshall
pruitt in westworld and the role of
benjamin caffrey on dexter
much of the mystery of stranger things 4
revolves around victor creel the man
convicted of brutally murdering his
family decades earlier in the episode
titled chapter 4 dear billy nancy and
robin interview victor about his
experience in the hopes of putting
together a strategy against vecna's
attacks and they don't leave
disappointed victor tells them the full
story of what really happened to him at
his family's seemingly haunted home
setting the rest of the story in motion
given that stranger things season 4
pulls heavily from the nightmare on elm
street movies it makes sense that the
creators wanted to get a proper cameo
from freddy krueger himself robert
englund in addition to playing one of
cinema's most infamous slashers for
decades england also had prominent roles
in a number of genre films and in tv
series like fear clinic downtown and the
original v miniseries from 1983. he's
also an accomplished voice actor with
credits that include anti-pops on
regular show vulture on the spectacular
spider-man and aethrac in dota dragon's
blood
after all she went through at the end of
stranger things season 3 max mayfield
has more than a little bit of trauma to
work through it's not every day that you
see your stepbrother torn to pieces by
an otherworldly monster max ends up in
sessions with miss kelly the counselor
at hawkins high though she doesn't
exactly play a central role in the story
miss kelly appears in a number of scenes
and unwittingly gives max and the crew
the key to part of vechna's mystery miss
kelly is played by regina ting chen a
prolific actor in the tv space in
addition to a variety of small tv roles
her biggest credits include the role of
chandler tong in black lightning
katherine nakai in queen of the south
and dr julia cho in woke
to put it mildly jim hopper has a bad
time in stranger things season 4. he's
captured by soviet soldiers brutally
tortured and stuck on an icy chain gang
with no clear means of escape
fortunately he ends up making an ally in
dmitry a guard who agrees to help hopper
get away in the hopes of a major payday
things don't exactly go as planned and
hopper and dimitri are forced to get to
know each other and work together in a
number of dangerous situations their
dynamic is fun to watch throughout and
dimitri provides a nice counter to
hopper's grim persona if you're a fan of
game of thrones then you'll probably
recognize actor tom lashia as the
mystical assassin jaqen h'ghar on hbo's
blockbuster fantasy series well at least
he plays the most memorable version of
jaqen a shapeshifter who repeatedly
changes faces over the course of the
story you may also remember him as
sebastian burger from the crime drama
series crossing lines or as max schenkel
in tom clancy's jack ryan
in order to get to russia and help break
hopper free joyce and murray employ the
skills of a smuggler named yori jovial
and silly at first yori quickly reveals
himself to be a tricky man with a lot of
hidden intentions up his sleeve equally
wacky and deceptive in nature yuri is a
bit of a loose cannon and he brings a
frenetic energy to stranger things
season 4's soviet plotline i'm sorry
poor bird
did i make your coffee too strong
serbian actor nichola jericho brings
guerry to life in stranger things and
his acting resume is quite a long one
much of his work prior to appearing in
the netflix series is on various serbian
tv shows such as open doors frozen stiff
and the storks will return american
audiences may know him as darko in
angelina jolie's in the land of blood
and honey tamir on the tnt show legends
and laura gramos on the bbc miniseries
informer jericho has also appeared in
projects like world war z and for all
mankind
the first episode of stranger things 4
focuses largely on chrissy cunningham a
new character and member of the hawkins
high cheerleading squad chrissy is the
first target of vecna who subjects her
to a series of horrifying nightmare
visions that drive her to buy drugs from
eddie munson unfortunately she doesn't
even get an attempt at respite before
vecna returns in full ghastly force
setting up the major events of the
season chrissy is played by grace van
dien who netflix viewers might recognize
as brooke osmond from the teen drama
series greenhouse academy she also had a
major role as katie campbell on nbc's
the village additionally she's had
sizable roles in movies like writing
faith and the binge van dean has
appeared on a number of other tv series
including the rookie the moral compass
and white famous
when jason carver begins his vigilante
quest to hunt down eddie munson he
brings a whole crew of his friends and
hawkins high teammates with him most of
these characters don't get much in the
way of lines or scream time the one
exception being patrick who ends up a
little more important to the show than
the rest of the pack sadly patrick gets
targeted by vecna later in the season
leading to a brutal lake confrontation
patrick might not get a lot in the way
of character development but he does
play an important role in one of the
most memorable scenes of stranger things
4. though he's still quite young actor
miles truitt already has a number of
major credits to his name in addition to
his role as patrick in stranger things
you may recognize him as b mickey from
the star series bmf as ant on ava
duvernay's queen sugar or as issa
williams on black lightning truit also
appeared in shows like superstition and
movies like dragged across concrete
one of vecna's many teenage targets in
stranger things 4 is fred nancy's second
in command at the hawkins high school
newspaper fred investigates the murder
of chrissy cunningham with nancy hoping
to uncover something that the town's
adult media outlets might have missed
unfortunately for him he gets distracted
by a series of visions sent straight
from the upside down that conjure up
memories of a traumatic car accident
from his past with no prior experience
with the supernatural fred is
understandably unable to fend off
feckner's psychic assault i want you
to join me
the actor behind fred is logan reilly
bruner who you might know as lance from
the marvelous mrs maisel bruner's other
credits include a part in natalie
portman's vox lux and the netflix film
alex strangelove he's also contributed
brief turns on unbreakable kimmy schmidt
and orange is the new black
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite characters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one